sommes-nous seuls dans l'univers c'est
une question que tout le monde se pose
depuis la nuit des temps depuis des
millénaires c et reviennent sur la terre
on pense que nous sommes nous les
terriens le résultat d'une de leurs
expériences univers est si basse qu'il
est fort probable que d'autres formes de
vie existent
d'après une étude parue le mois dernier
de scientifiques chinois ou angie sont
guéris gao estime qu'il pourrait y avoir
entre 111 et 42000 civilisations
intelligentes extraterrestes
communicante dans notre galaxie
calcul a été effectué par rapport au
nombre de planètes habitables connu et
la fréquence à laquelle la vie sur cette
planète évolué
bref vous l'avez compris nous sommes
encore loin d'avoir tout découvert sur
le monde qui nous entoure
[Musique]
les extraterrestres sommes-nous seuls
dans notre galaxie gilles verdez vous à
mon ami je pense que et croit sais pas
d'où vous venez mais à mon avis c'est un
peu chelou vous croyez crois énormément
la question c'est pourquoi comme ils
sont 42 milo moi pourquoi est ce qu'ils
ne viennent pas nous rencontrer
rapidement votre gueule
et moi salon mais un faux c'est parce
que ils ont peur d'arriver enterré selon
positive il faudrait oui j'ai enquêté ah
oui il faudrait qu'on soit plus gentil
avec eux non parce que sinon mais oui
ils ont peur et cee ils viennent pour
nous serrer la main nous embrasser le
câline et nous les rôles des alcôves
idem et seysses au delà de tout ça quoi
mais tu penses qu'à des intervient sur
mais tu vois qu'ils ont qu'elle te dis
je pense qu'ils sont des objets et un
mois c'est à travers ces enfin
je vois que je ne juge pas il se cache
dans l'étude concourait avec sa poêle à
bois 3 heures du matin frère
je te dis je veux pas peut-être que pas
prendre un cachet au passé
riche dans les arbres et les boulots
bien sûr
il n'est pas quoi il ya des exemples
dans les plats très beau et bien sûr la
station exelmans moyens non et non mais
toi c'est toi à la station exelmans et
répond bien sûr ce qui t'a fait l'arbre
ben je lui parle régulièrement je
défends sur l'a9 souvent pour lui parler
seulement à evry dans l'essonne y en a
où je vais régulièrement le conscient le
classico masse à la maison tu fais pas
toujours mais dans une heure je parle à
mon art
bien sûr mais oui mais c'est vrai que
j'aimerais que tu as à tarbes comme ça
mais c'est une confrérie de personnes ça
parce qu'au lac de virer à
viry-châtillon il ya beaucoup de gens
qui se réunissent au chalet sont aussi
mais bien sûr kelly l'essonne c'est un
territoire d'extraterrestres avec bien
évidemment les rapports et les
extraterrestres
[Rires]
qui a une expérience extra terrestre est
en fait un soir en sortant de tpm paix
passés par le bois de boulogne j'ai cru
voir
et quand il m'a demandé 50 euros j'ai
compris que c'était bien de venir il
s'appelait roberto mais il avait une
tête bizarre
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
barre toi et fais nous une omelette
norvégienne
lensois n'ont sinon nous sommes ou con
là pour ce soir à l'appétit sous des
dates abri dans cette étude elle
explique qu'en fait tu peux pas leur
avoir parlé puisque en gros ce que nous
expliquent les chercheurs c'est que si
on peut avoir une conversation ben idir
excuses appel bidirectionnelle c'est à
dire l'un avec l'autre c'est minimum
dans 2000 ans maximum dans 4000 ans
c'est à dire que peut-être notre
civilisation sera éteinte quand on
arrive à me donner des leçons
d'extraterrestres bainimarama
s'est laissé les chercheurs en question
justement et qui disent qu'ils enfin ce
serait absolument incroyable et un
mystère absolu al'inverse que nous
soyons seuls dans l'univers c'est ce
qu'ils ont mais c'est sûr qu'on n'est
pas seul voilà l associu alors ceux des
pauvres
alors vous sait pas alors j'ai commencé
vraiment à
mais ce petit corps parce qu'en fait
parce que tu sais peut-être mon grand
père était très féru de tout ça oui
voyez s'assure du sud régulièrement
ses deux grands pères il a envoyé passé
louis saez régulière moi j'en ai déjà
taillé au caire comme l'âge et la purée
de rabat et à luiz et ya fait toute sa
tête
c'est des
balades le corps
extraterrestre alors pas extra terreste
mais il m'expliquer mais moi je ne le
voyais pas mais je le croyais me disais
tiens voilà il ya encore lui cette
attaque mais ça devrait passer par la
force et d'autres idées comme
et astrologue et donc
il m'avait prédit que j'allais trop rien
avec un costume sombre
aujourd'hui
il va toujours dit qu'il rencontrerait
quelqu'un de très élégant las heras un
croque-mort tout simplement
[Rires]
raconter meneceur électorale le corps
astra n'est pas basse et entend par là
soir il dit comment il voit la valeur
des fantômes franchement oui bah oui on
appartient martiaux photo les deux
martien pendant que je vivais des
martiens mais chez vous ah oui chez moi
bien sûr mais qu'est ce que c'est que si
vous avez peur banon et c'est connu on
peut rentrer avec tous les interphones
elle
sait qu'il a passé le pc sécurité
pour raconter l'histoire
quelle maison dans quel pays en fait
france pari et
ouais et se sont retrouvés non monsieur
georges avait des martiens la maison
mais non mais a laissé revenir au
sommaire et c'est esthétique comme ça
abbas et c'est ça sent les petits
copains
des anciens du nébouzan dans un jardin
en quoi est ce qu'il ya des boulots de
la fesci le boulot vous avez échangé
avec eux bien sûr brawn est devenus
potes non monsieur jean remy zé vraie
vie on va faire des dark à tous un sas
avait initié au paddle patin dans vos
enfants
maintenant tu me le dire
il faut peut-être voir ouais vous avez
une expérience extra terrien non moi j'y
crois pas du tout moi je crois que ce
que je vois et en fait je n'ai jamais
rien vu donc j'y crois pas du tout pour
moi ça oui c'est
tout ce qui est des films aliens yachts
et ghostbusters est tous assez haute et
vous de tout et vous wifi c'est
mon film intérêts pour sa légèreté des
fantasmes hollywoodiens pour pour des
enfants un peu comme jean ont fait un
peu dégénéré comme ça
dans mes bras est-ce que tu as une
histoire nous raconte en fait c'est un
peu ce que racontait daniel j ai un
soldat qui était à la bataille de
waterloo et qui la nuit
et chose avec moi pour comprendre
pourquoi napoléon a perdu c'est sûr elle
est simple un mari patron chinois
regardez tous les moyens
l'amande fatou il est dans l'armée
[Applaudissements]
non mais bien sûr c'est des histoires
nocturne et je suis à la bataille de
waterloo avec lui je comprends pas
pourquoi on a perdu donc c'est très bien
à ton tour d'accord mais c'est vrai